[Music]
it is a big day here in Hollywood as
Emmy nominations were handed out there
were some surprising nominees and some
surprising snubs and of course we were
in the middle of it all eleven
nominations for NBC's newcomer this is
us the cast just blown away my phone
just started blowing up so I knew
something was going on I had to ask a
couple times like did you read it right
is it real so um but then I was like and
here's the surprise guest star Gerald
McRaney gets his first Emmy nod I don't
think it's quite hit me yet I mean I am
pumped I really am a big day for
blackish I don't want to pop anybody in
now our nischelle Turner was with stars
Anthony Anderson and Tracee Ellis Ross
these things make you nervous because
you wouldn't you know I mean so I
decided to put on a mask a moisture mask
on my face and sit in meditation it's
time to win don't tell me that tell the
voters Michelle Turner voters nominees
for lead actors in a comedy series are
et on lines Lee Ann Aguilera was there
as the names were read and to
congratulate beeps Anna Chlumsky
congratulations your fifth consecutive
Emmy nomination it's surreal because
like it's not every day one it's not
every day that you're nominated and
there's an Oscar winner showdown Nicole
and Reese of HBO's big little lies and
Susan and Jessica from FX's feud Betty
and Joan all nominated in the same
category and there were some snubs today
Oprah completely shut out for Best
Actress in a limited series and Jimmy
Fallon did not receive a nomination for
The Tonight Show and one more nomination
to note the late Carrie Fisher was
recognized for her guest shot on the
Amazon series catastrophe
you